welcome everyone thank you very much for
coming my name is Oliver be a [ __ ] and
I'm a student here at you divinity
school and pretty and I were organizing
this event and we are very grateful to
the panelists here and for coming here
and it's also we are grateful to the
organization's for sending them here and
we're very fortunate to have these
panelists and our bond director
professor Scott because they have kind
of first-hand experience of Burma and
and I like to introduce our panelists to
you the first panelist is Google's EDA
is he's up there in the end the
suffering color ghazi that was one of
the leaders of saffron revolution in 90
night 2007 September and he is currently
a member of all murmur monks alliance
and raising awareness among American
public about political situations in
Burma and you have hangouts about their
short biographies there's more details
in that and the second panelist is Myra
Myra dagger poor she's right here and
she's she belongs to current ethnic
group in Burma and she's currently
working for us campaign for Burma and
Mara is also a member of current women's
organization and a board member of
Korean American communities foundation
and our third panelist is jose santa is
there he is he's a long-lost friend of
mine I first met him in Rangoon in 1993
when where I was a high school student
and when he was working for the British
Embassy and before that he worked as a
faculty member of
goon Arts and Science University and he
was dismissed from his position for his
allegedly involvement in 1988 political
uprising and then Joe Santa has worked
for the BBC Burmese service for 13 years
as a journalist and editor and is
currently working as an editor for voice
of america memory service and he studied
history at Rangoon University and
international politics at London
University and our professor James Scott
is right here and he is the only he is
the one and only vamos para specialist
at Yale and very grateful for his
support for this this public forum on
democracy in Burma today he will be
moderating our panel discussions and
professor Scott is sterling professor of
political science and also professor of
anthropology at Yale he has written many
books especially around the area of
peasants resistance against central
domination in Southeast Asia his recent
book is is a very interesting one it is
its title is not being governed I'm
getting it correct not the overlap the
art of not being governed and it's it's
about the how he'll people in Southeast
Asia use Christianity and enemies them
Exeter 22 as a source of resistance and
distance from the domination of the
lowland people and mostly I'm very
grateful to Southeast Asia console at yo
for funding this event I submitted the
funding proposal are on October 4 1030
p.m. at night and the next morning I
woke up and to my surprise it was
already approved
and this shows the seriousness of yield
University in supporting Burmese
democracy as an urgent issue for public
discussions and debates I'm particularly
grateful to Christine manager of
Southeast Asia Council who has worked
tirelessly over the past three weeks we
organized this in three weeks time so
she has given me all the directions and
closed back up for organizing this event
link without her help this event would
not be possible I'm also grateful to
Prudie and friends from Amnesty
International student group and for
publicizing this event and I want to say
thank you to Yale Divinity School for
supporting our event with AV services
and many other things and I'm grateful
to friends and volunteers for this event
I'm very inspired by the enormous
support and assistance I have received
from friends professors and staff
members at year over the past three
weeks I hope our public forum will not
only promote awareness and critical
public discussions about democracy in
Burma but also inspire other Burmese
students study in different countries
and different institutions to initiate a
similar public forum and discussion and
we like to start a panel discussion with
Google go see that
diggin oozing put her mouth was only
near georgia maría de fuego my PPR
incision media dr seasonable gory to the
PA with the new year or ninja monkey
mutiny Talara mom yahoo within the comp
you in your pajamas on Jeju tenia losing
touch my I would like to thank the
organizers of this vet and for those who
attend ain't this event who's here a
mere row who goaded acaba de una llamada
movido bada bada yonder wat URL my name
is gatita i was born in Burma and I am a
Buddhist monk cover me using the Buddha
abundance abuse and Anita you arrogant
video using lilach a day at the NSA to
otakon each akebono I study Buddhism
since I was 12 years at all years Oh i
lo ba da ba da sabi nila na with a new
luda Luden's hua Luo danza a larva DNA
within us as i get a certain grade a
comma with a new morning and senior EP
DJ Damien starting to any arm as I was
studying Buddhism and I was also in
contact with the people and I study that
the people of Burma are suffering and
getting poor hello we're gonna be
anonymous eid mubarak italy losing coo
coo coo p invito donde no lo merece una
galloway among women lingua song gently
luminaries who are to the del amo mucho
a comma within cuckoos in yami rotunda a
soldier tuning am Ghidorah bosnia in
italy showed up um i was looking at the
people suffering
and I can see that people wants to do to
become a prosperous however I see I
learn more and more what is the cause of
that problem era una imagen de loop
tibia need a laser cutter 00 d move easy
correct Lola swab do so lool asahi to
again Lola so October guinsoo a
democracy sato mujo with anupama be duty
senior Duke Aiona guess what I wouldn't
agere and I learned that bama is
suffering from freedom of writing
freedom of press freedom of religion
that's why baba is poor hello tiga
rachel azevedo using lugana tubulin NEPA
u janu D McKinney Jones raga the HMV
with a nice chain rule within Cooney
social de lobo son team vedoe not count
laguna honda brio is insulting loca by
with antenna selenium after i learning
more and more I started helping the
hiv/aids patients at Megan monastery
since 2004 tiller de Luna oh no kuni la
na na so you know nanjing hagia
retweeted amore mio and hid in sonarika
ma 2007 sword este tema poet Ovid
objetivo know as I was helping those
patients and the country get into deeper
and deeper troubles that's why I got
involved in the 2007 saffron revolution
I know people are a koala bear who they
are Jonah bhaduri tanga Rory go along
whoo whoo qi ghana kusama hands pri-med
over tea tomorrow you janu Jen Jen Jen
Jen get a boo boo Yong Yong Yong Yong
LAN choco taco was in so oviedo oh so we
were locatable during that saffron
revolution I let the students and monks
by holding up
the bullhorn to protest peacefully and
to be disciplined I know with a
non-union Union a local ha nava eulogy
nang emotion desi arnaz in apollo she
say on a shindig on davido depot india
our two universes aniversario quere with
ronan engineer located arugula where
Numa Bielema money now ol like beer or
near by state HIV pants idiot roger
ebert tequila gave our a the military
regime cracked down the peaceful
protesters and they make those protester
and live over in Burma so that's why i
have to flee varma alutia a comedy natok
una cuna de amalah eyah nima tiny
amanezca booya day aria nibblers in
metal chick una donna by ma america and
angora pugio navarre i arrived to
thailand in 2007 december fifth and i
came to the united states our march two
thousand eight as a particle refugee
hello do yoga John Oliver will know
tomorrow blue jean in a year davido
would you know located i wouldnt we
attend mi chica that we do not drool
okay there tomorrow d who is a new
tonight rock Cooney be a teamily between
Obama madhavi a butta butta Cleary who
you know massari Timmy day now tolerate
tangara Rahul away with no hootenanny on
DVD burner he said a man EP Loretta hour
ago with a new tonight a bug on TV da
cunha v beret a car ally of our glue the
Garuda tonymoly with a new like you over
here i am living here as a refugee and i
continue of my work on burma by
supporting the monks who were able to
come to the United States and also I
teach a Burmese language to the Burmese
children and also we help
those monks were able to flee Burma and
now living in Thailand and other areas
and also we do this kind of discussions
and go around the country and to talk
about Burma and 0 VAR e new yokoyama do
dhari tubulin any goo Goo's innova Benny
away yo yo subby do lobo me through the
employee in there within yeah my ginger
go but within pure java ray no mom
mikuni question you mean Emily I can
promise you that I will keep working for
the humanity and I will continue to do
so our acts more questions later on if
you have any thanks
good afternoon everyone thank you very
much for coming and I'm really thankful
to the organizers professors God for
making this happen as you heard my name
is Myra dally poor from the Quran ethnic
groups from Burma and right now I am a
campaign coordinator for the u.s.
campaign for Burma and the yes campaign
for Burma is a US based organization
dedicated to empower the grassroot
activists around the world and also in
the US in order to raleigh for human
rights and to bring an end of the
military regime in Burma and our mission
is to build up a broad-based coalition
of the grassroots and Internet
institution and support for freedom in
Burma through public education
leadership development initiatives and
then also our conferences and advocacy
campaign and also we work with
policymakers in the States as well as
well especially in the States in order
to increase the global pressure on Burma
military regime in an effort towards are
realizing of freedom in Burma in should
I assume that you might already know
that the Burmese has been ruled by the
successive military regime since
nineteen sixty-two and the people of
Burma have been oppressed suffered for
various kinds of human rights abuses
including but not limited to forced
displacement force labor torturous
systematic and systematics and gang rape
and also murdered by the Burmese
military troops for decades but these
stories has been taken has been getting
our very little attention of the
international community and so for many
years the international community has
watched human rights nightmare that has
been going on
and the Nobel Peace Prize winner on thur
Sergey and almost about 22,000 sorry
2200 political prisoners are still in
jail and also at the same time the
Buddhist monks are included and until
two thousand seven the mark uprising
when Oh gazeta pick up the leadership
roles and that's when the Burma a
situation got more international
attention but then still the ethnic
issues are getting very little attention
so from a personal witness the Burmese
military regime has destroyed more than
3,500 villages in eastern Burma alone
started from two 1996 in this code we
can compare these to the villages that
destroyed in Sudan and also in the same
in some cases soldiers foes the
villagers to destroy their own villages
to destroy their own corpse animals and
then get rid of the village and also on
top of that more than a million people
from Burma that have to flat for
violence and oppression and then they
become the refugee in Thailand and also
India and Bangladesh Malaysia and on top
of that six hundred thousand villages
are hiding in jungle and caves as the
internally displaced person where I was
for more than 10 years their homes were
burned down the villages and everything
was destroyed and on top of that the
military troops planted landmines in the
village so that the villages cannot come
back and collect whatever stove they
have left in the village so meaning that
they have to get out there built up
another village but then from there the
military troops come in and find out
about the new village burned it down
again
the land mines and then these people has
to keep on fleeing from one place to
another um the first time I remember
fleeing for lives when I was about seven
years old it was raining season and one
thing that I remember very well was that
is that it was raining season and I had
to sleep under a plastic trap and the
plastic trap wasn't big enough so my
upper part of body was cover and so I
was protected by the rain but my body
power body part was in the rain so I was
wet but sleeping in the rain helped with
half of my body and I was so hungry
asking for food and I was given a feast
of white rice but at the time it was so
hard for me to understand why MA the
same place didn't get to eat rice why I
get to advise alone but eventually I
learned that I was the youngest one in
the family and perhaps my family might
afraid that I'm when I'm too hungry i'm
going to start crying and it's going to
get loud and we're going to get captured
by the troops so I was sort of like
comfort by that little feast of rice and
oh I also remember that there were many
times that we had to run for lives in a
year and there was one time that I was I
think I was about 10 years old when I
remember we had to flee for life twice
in a month and there was one night in
the middle of the night my uncle came
over and rush me he was like pick up
your bag and go with everyone to the to
the river where the boat is and I pick
up my bag and I went to the river where
everyone was and then eventually we were
taken to the other side of the Selwyn
river on the on the Thai soil and then
we went over in jungle to hide there for
about a week and after that
I learned from my uncle and other men in
the village that our village was burned
down completely and there was nothing
left but then we couldn't go back and
after a week when things were calm down
and then my uncle and other men received
the news that okay the the troops were
gone nobody was there anymore anymore
then my uncle and other men they were
like okay we'll go back to the village
to see if there is anything that we can
pick up we can bring over to our family
in order to feed them or whatever we can
use in a month eng and among the them my
one of my aunts distance aunt she also
went with a group and the bad news was
that on on our way back to the village
she stepped on a landmine so her left
side was totally destroyed so she lost a
lot of blood and my uncle trying to
another man they're trying to bring her
to the closest jungle mobile clinic
mobile clinic but then our before she
reached her cleaning she already kind of
like lost too much blood and she died so
I mean this is my personal story in my
family my relatives but it's not a
unique one and there are hundreds of
thousands of the people in Burma that
have to suffer what I have suffered but
then our stories hasn't been told enough
and the international community has
known very little about us and they have
done nothing yet
but then meanwhile the international
community is also waiting for a
tangerine and the the military troops to
reform to change their the strategy of
their ruling over over Burma but do you
think is this going to happen right now
we are as the campaign boots we're also
trying to campaign for the commission of
inquiry but then a lot of government
they were saying okay we'd until the
election is over we'll see if there's
any change but one thing that I'd like
to tell you this evening is that I don't
expect aspect the change will come after
this november seventh election so I mean
what are two important things that I
wanted to bring about to your attention
about the Burma election that will be
coming up on november seven is that the
first thing instead of the Constitution
instead instead of the people the voices
of people of the people of Burma get I
may get out there in the international
arena we are kind of like pushed down by
the many international commuter many
international countries because we're
trying to put with this e that we're
trying to put the regime into kind of
like to pressure them to come to to put
them on to the the the witness stand or
punishment but then also on the other
hand the regime is coming up with
there's a constitution and we're saying
that this continue the Constitution is
not going to be too mean anything
because this constitution is this
constitution is already reserved
twenty-five percent for the military
seeds and this twenty-five percent is
going is granting for both the national
and then then the state legislative
bodies and then the second thing is that
even
if it is true for the Democratic
opposition to let's say miraculously
when the left over 75 of the percent of
the seat but this still don't have
enough to to amend the Constitution
without the support of the military
because this twenty-five percent is
given to the military and so it means
that this Democratic opposition cannot
rule the country but also on top of that
what is wrong with this Burma
constitution is that this constitution
ensure that the military will have the
power to control over the sea the
citizens on their daily basis on on
daily basis on their daily life so the
commander-in-chief will appoint by the
minister will appoint that the
ministries of the defense or the Home
Affairs or the border Affairs so meaning
that here it's only the military that
has the power after all and I I don't
really want to go into so much into the
election but I also wanted to live it
for the so for this space for
question-and-answer to see what you
might be interested in asking or knowing
it more about this constitution but what
I just wanted to conclude with today is
that I mean the people of Burma are
suffering and they are hiding in yoga
and case and the the political prisoners
are still in jail and then on sausage is
still under house arrest and we have no
clue when she's going to be released so
meaning that the people of Burma we have
no voice and so meaning that we don't
have any way of
expecting to have a civil government
after this election and therefore Burma
would just as much of a military
dictatorship after november seventh
election Thank you Thank You mera kuch
aur Zelda good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen first of all I would like to
distance myself from voice of america
I'm working as a journalist with voice
of america but now what I'm talking is
only my old opinion nothing to do with
Voice of America and that second thing I
would like to tell is I am NOT an
activist like I'm not done here oh I'm
sitting between two activists Huber
activist I'm Gaza journalism so I'm
we're not supposed to take sides
although I have a strong desire strong
wish for a democratic Burma free bummer
I'm not an activist maybe I'm talking
about what I think and what I see I'm
talking about the difficulties on the
road to democracy in Burma the military
dictatorship is the stone wall on the
road to democracy in Burma now they
everybody as everybody knows since
nineteen sixty two primaries on a milky
dictatorship and there was an election
in 1990 and national league for
democracy won a landslide victory no
part transfer the military junta changed
its name and now they are going to have
another election in a week time and yes
as Maya has suggested this election is
not free and fair election at all it
won't be the Constitution I mentioned
yesterday she said twenty-five percent
reserved for the military and it will be
a presidential executive a president
will appoint the chief of
commander-in-chief and
commander-in-chief of the power to take
control of the state whenever he deemed
there
is a threat for that disintegrate for
the integration of the Union so he has
every right to take on throughout the
country again they mentioned in the
Constitution trav what what is the their
the principal basic principles of the
Constitution one of the principal is
military will play an important role in
national politics in Burma that is the
most important thing so we want to have
a permanent coup whatever is going on in
Burma and then in this election there
will be two legislature padulla door and
news outlet or upper house and lower
house about 300 in the lower house and
upper houses about 150 seats there and
state and state and regional
legislatures all together there will be
about 1200 constituency's so only the
Milky proxy party um DP United Union
development and solidarity party will
contest in all the constituency in all
the 1200 constituency and another body
contesting in all constituency is the nu
p national unity party that is the
successor of the long-ruling perma
socialist program party under generally
win regime bspp so these two party one
is the Milky proximity another one is
the bspp generally wins success of
general Nivens party so Democratic
parties have only 160 candidates and
another party has only 57 candidates it
is impossible for the Democratic parties
to win the elections and to form a
government to share power or not it
nothing at all but there are some hope
as he mentioned you know some gov some
foreign governments are still expecting
some structural change after the
elections
and they are hoping a chance to talk to
their new government newly elected
government so as I see there will be no
direct change in structural or in any
other way in power sharing or nothing at
all but we can expect some indirect
change maybe it is very likely hood is
very low but it is possible because some
countries they want to do business
inside Burma they want to invest in
Burma we will have an pre-tax our excuse
to do business in Burma they will say
look there is a constitutional
government it is elected government so
that we can do business with Burma so
through those business contact maybe
Burma in neighbouring countries like
China India and the ASEAN they will do
they will do more investment in Burma so
it may be that it cannot make
development to some extent only for the
cronies but they may later eventually
have a growth of middle class in Burma
there is no middle class at all at the
moment so through them you know they
will create more space for them to do
more business for their own interest
there will be more schools possibly or
through that eventually that may lead
that ammo crate sector mahadi process
that is the only slight hook regarding
this elections no other as no other
expedition and that is the major problem
there is a stone wall towards the
democracy in Burma of course there are
some other disturbances let's call it a
stumbling blocks towards the democracy
in Burma the first thing is this unity
everywhere except the mail tree they
never reveal even if there is a disunity
among themselves they can resolve final
resolution among themselves but in
opposition as well and a diversity among
the between the ethnic peoples and the
barman's they are diversity and
differences that also
is a stumbling block to watch Marcus in
Burma and if we look at the history
after independence immediately after the
independence that communists they don't
they didn't accept the independence as a
genuine independence and they rebel
against the newly formed stage union of
burma and they went underground and some
other groups political groups followed
suit that's how the civil war began in
Burma and we never recover from that
silver stripes since then still it is
there and another disunity is the
disunity division among the ruling AFP
FL Andy fascism people's freedom leak
and that difference that division led
the military coup you know generally
wind took opportunity of that division
and he came to power then at still
hanging around in Burma that we are
still under the military dictatorship
but the main causes are the division and
disunity among their politicians so the
same thing happened more or less today
in facing their upcoming elections
national league for democracy
everybody's looking forward to hear what
national league for democracy will
decide regarding this elections and
national effort Berkeley said they
bright watch the election but they do
not instigate the people to buy for the
elections instead they said you know you
have to wash a closed eyes the election
process and you have to complain to
launch the complaint accordingly if
there are some malpractices in elections
so people who are undecided what are
they going to do who are they going to
cast the vote for they voted for the
National League for Democracy the
uncensored g-spot in 1990 elections the
same thing they are happen now looking
forward this time and nationally for
democracy is the only party the only
organization that can challenge the
the military government in the elections
so they have nowhere to go they don't
know until now last minute the people of
amaru know who they have to cast their
vote for the left more that is one
disunity and diversity between the
ethnic people and the Berman's people
from bama proper actually the diversity
is moral as the vertical diversity the
ruling class and the ordinary people
there is no clash hora genet clash
between the ethnic people and the
barman's but at me people wants to have
a genuine federal union that is the
pretext for the military government they
want to integrate a union they want to
separate from bama that's why they came
to power in 1962 that is they said that
actually the bum knee is not only the
Bombers Maori the bum and some elements
of varmints they it is very difficult
for them to understand what a general
that the essence of the Federation means
they still thought they are
indoctrinated for the 50 years not since
nineteen sixty-two by the military
government consecutively military
regimes the Federation is there this
integration of the Union so we will have
to do those things as well if you want
to go to democracy and foreign
international community attitudes and
their assistants toward democracy and
Burma international community also is
not United there is no concerted effort
for democratizing Burma for nudging the
mail tree for democratization
neighbouring countries like asean-china
India they are doing something different
they want to engage they want to do
business they want to have a lion's
share in Burma whereas the american-led
in all Western democracies want to give
sanctions even then the American
there when Obama came to presidency they
are trying to tone down they want to do
engagement as well as sanctions
character and state policy they said so
there are a lot of difficulties we have
to face and two if you want to have the
democracy in Burma so the only hope is
at the moment that the eventual process
maybe there will be some space to widen
the middle class and those player of the
middle class through the business
investment they will create new jobs
from the Polish people maybe at least
through the investment of the
neighboring countries most schools more
education for them and we the foreign
foreign media foreign radio stations the
problem with us is we were not allowed
we are not allowed to cover the election
process so we have to give up we can do
anything from outside we have our
contact from inside but they don't have
free access to the election process at
all so it is very difficult situation to
democratize Burma so thank you thank you
very much I think we should open it to
any questions you have for any of the
panelists I thought I'd say something
just in an introductory way I want to
thank Oliver for organizing this it's
actually his baby he brought it up he
conceived it and although the Southeast
Asia council has helped to fund it he's
the man responsible so I want
the in this is a way of framing this a
little bit in 1960 I'm told the fort
foundation the Ford Foundation was
deciding which countries of Southeast
Asia were the most promising and they
decided that Burma was the most
promising at that point in 1960 rangoon
and Bangkok were more or less equivalent
cities about the same population the
same level of development and the fort
foundation decided Burma was a very good
bet the comparison now between the level
of development in thailand and bangkok
and rangoon and in the countryside in
particular is the difference between
night and day the education system the
medical system has been bankrupt for
more than half a century so this is a
military regime that's now been in power
for half a century and they have it
seems to me more or less destroyed the
life chances of two generations of
Burmese and the election facade that
they have erected as Joan jajaja was
saying will allow ASEAN and and China
and India to do business with Burma
because it appeared to have an election
and the result of this is simply likely
to be a scramble for the resources of
Burma that are already being plundered
it with the disguise of having had at
least the facade of an election let me
stop there and open it to any questions
you have for any member of the panel